[Musique]
à peine libéré de sa tutelle la star
américaine britney spears révèle être
enceinte
elle est enceinte de son troisième
enfant âgé de 40 ans est déjà maman de
deux enfants elle a annoncé la grande
nouvelle à ses fans sur instagram j'ai
fait un test de grossesse est bon
j'attends un bébé elle même surprise
elle évoque la possibilité d'avoir des
jumeaux une nouvelle mode qui touche
déjà plusieurs tares de plus de 40 ans
comme céline dion eva longoria ou encore
marion cotillard on n'est pas à l'abri
que daniel moreau nous fasse un petit
avant la fin de la saison qui à cannes
un jour viendra peut-être
[Applaudissements]
il s'enferre c'est le commandant
cousteau
[Rires]
non mais sans déconner le damné moreau
qui est un enfant mon père ça serait
magnifique ah oui j'ai envie d'être là
comme a poussé poussé je le vois
mais très neuf
il ya un enfant qui a prié pour l'école
et il a raison mais à une commode
m
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean poupelain
mais c'est une super nouvelle pour elle
cela dit
l'époque elle a été libérée de la
tutelle de son père c'est vrai qu'elle
est libérée elle avait 18 deux enfants
de 15 ans et 16 ans elle n'a jamais eu
la garde ouais donc enfin la pouvoir
peut être avoir un enfant et entend
pourquoi pas
il ya plein de gens qui accuse son
nouveau mari sa masse grille de profiter
d'elle parce qu'il ya douze ans - parce
qu'ils étaient complètement inconnus en
sortie avec elle et parce qu'il a une
fortune de 60 millions au cap la voix
qui pensent que c'est une fortune de 60
watts ce qui n'est pas énorme elle était
l'aînée à 205
1950 à la 60 millions d'euros candidats
et surtout elle n'a pas pu en profiter
du tout qui vous a donné la parole à
m'en excuser mon âge mais elle est
saisie non mais elle n'a pas pu en
profiter elle avait son père qui lui
mettait qui la mettait sous tutelle il a
obligé à garder un stérilet certains
pouvaient même pas faire d'enfant pour
nous d'imaginer annoncée de la torture
psychologique fans où on a grandi avec
britney on est ravis qu'elle fasse un
nom dans mais c'est vrai que quand on
sait que la formule de fortune de brut
michel passe tes chaussettes et à 2 105
61 dollars de dollars au moment de la
tutelle aujourd'hui il en reste 60 elle
a quasiment plus rien à ses 600 millions
c'est très peu par bieber c'est 400
millions aujourd'hui à peu près de
rosser
fait un enfant il a tout gagné la cisba
ça fait longtemps qu'ils sont ensemble
mais c'est plus grand chose les stars
qui n'ont plus rien whitney houston côté
les morts il y avait 18 millions d'euros
de patrimoine auront à huy a vécu rien
de rien longtemps
je vais travailler pour des salaires
le mec qui a fait long feu et daniel
mots elle a vaincu sesterces
sans rigoler un enfant 40 ans castaldi
toi table alors qu'en 50 ans doit donc
avec la femme à bâle avec elle avait 42
ans ah ouais enfin tu fais quoi moi je
suis pas du tout dans l'ambiance
biberons couches est tous à coucher son
concept
de 20 ans et voilà c'est un but du tout
là dedans bon ok nice et oui c'est sûr
marie veux pas
vraiment parler de
tout ça ou c'est oui vous à huy bien se
bat 40 ans avait prévu non mais vous
pouvez en avoir un deuxième un troisième
a 40 ans mais elle en a pas encore ce
bail déjà lancé le truc après t'as pas
forcément victoire elle en aura un
deuxième ou un troisième à 40 ans et
comme daniel bour et voilà un daniel
vous et vous mois que daniel chow chow
[Rires]
qu'on est une petite famille avec des
chiens un renault espace une maison je
pourrais la bouille av
ce
à
quoi sert le brouillard c'est que c'est
quoi la signification vraiment exact
puisque symboles et ses baisers
non
remplacés bouquet et je vais vous dire
que je vous le dis et je vous dire la
vérité on va pas on va pas dans daniel
comme ça
non mais s'en est mêlé c'est déjà il ya
deux portiques de sécurité
c'est comme à la banque en t'arrive tu
nous attend que l'autre porspoder les
pouvoirs ou égale à 2 non mais elle
savait gagner un sas de sécurité droite
est dans le sac à main ceintures à givet
alors ils jouent ni donc daniel c'est
pas n'importe quoi ni les noms mais je
vous le dis ah c'est vrai et c'est vrai
qu'à la banque est toujours pressé tu as
remarqué ou pas jma droite est pressé
d'aller à la banque on dirait que tu
crois qu'ils m'ont donnée l'oseille en
fait à chaque fois qu'ils te convoque en
bus c'est pour dire qu'on n'a plus raté
dans le sas de sécurité tu vas beaucoup
d'humour et l'autre
[Rires]
près ce que l'autre porte se refermer
avant de pousser sur la première mais
c'est vrai pas c'est vrai mais quand tu
vas d une bijouterie parfois ils
hésitent tu sens que tu sonnes
généralement un vrai réseau
c'était à melzer mais les quidams il est
15 heures dix autres gens mais c'est
fermé il ya un an
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m